il n'y a pas que sur terre que l'on
trouve des volcans toutes les planètes
rocheuses comme la nôtre mercure vénus
et mars ont honte une activité
volcanique et possède les leurres mars
détient même le record du plus haut
volcan du système solaire olympus n'est
plus en activité et qui culmine à 21
mille mètres d'altitude
à titre de comparaison le plus haut
volcan terrestre le mona l'oaci paix sur
l'île d'hawaï dans le pacifique grimpe à
4170 mètres au dessus du niveau de la
mer même en ajoutant les 5000 m situé
sous l'eau il ne lui arrive pas à la
cheville sur mercure des images
provenant de la sonde messenger de la
nasa semble aussi confirmer une ancienne
activité volcanique idem sur vénus grâce
aux informations de la mission magellan
on sait que cette planète comporte de
nombreux volcans et surtout est
probablement un volcanisme actif très
récent enfin sachez que si les planètes
gazeuses en sont par nature dépourvu
certains satellites de saturne et de
jupiter possède les leurs et que plus
près de chez nous la lune a aussi été le
théâtre d'une importante activité
volcanique